hello good morning it is time it is
Destiny 2 lightfall time uh it is a
beautiful cold 9 A.M it's earlier than
I'm used to but I am here with Jean-Luc
on the call and we are so excited to get
you through Destiny 2 lightfall we're
probably going to play the opening
campaign for a couple of hours here so
chat sound off let us let me know how uh
the sound is you know hearing you guys
let me know how my voice sounds how uh
Jean Lux audio sounds we're gonna take
some time to adjust some stuff while we
are in this very uh lovely uh loading
screen right here as we try to get in to
the game
yeah we are we are excited we've been
waiting for this day for a very long
time uh man it is
it's it's a it's a good time honestly
honestly it's raining where I'm at right
now it's uh it's cold it's wet stay
inside play Destiny
indeed same it is it is so dark outside
there's like no light coming into my
room it is raining outside as well it's
just it's like a perfect day to to be in
my Discord was going off everyone was
saying like oh it's a snow day where I
am so they canceled classes they you
know work told us to stay home so we're
just here uh ready to play Destiny and
I'm I'm honestly here for it I'm still
here yeah
it's exciting oh man
dude I've been listening to this menu
theme it's so good yeah it is oh my God
it's so good I bought the soundtrack but
I was intentional I I don't listen to
the soundtrack yet because I know it'll
spoil [__] um right like just like the
titles will spoil stuff dude like fill
in in the chat with like posting like
Theory spoilers he was putting the
spoiler tag in yeah like man I just
can't I can't [__] look at any of
this [__] and don't don't do this to me
I'm trying to avoid it
oh
I'm so excited I'm just looking at chat
right now we got some uh oh we got
someone saying that they love our Zelda
vids thank you that's not me that's
that's our very own Max uh Blumenthal
who's just a absolute Zelda badass but
I'm so glad we got a we got some Zelda
fans in here you got a bunch of people
in chat being like either they're trying
to log in which you know pain I feel
that uh but other folks are like hey
they don't have school today they don't
got work today it is just Destiny and
that is what a great day for it honestly
a change of pace to be excited about
Destiny yeah you want to change your
face who would have who would have
thought man who would have thought you
know you and me have been been singing
Destiny's Praises for years but
[Music]
um
man dude yeah like uh every time we've
tried to like talk about Destiny on the
internet for years it's always been like
oh Destiny that's lame or just you know
like whatever like just people saying
[__] about the game but it's like and
enter like I'm not I'm not saying like
the game is like above criticism like
dude sure yeah weird [__] that Angie has
done over the years that is absolutely
but
all I'm saying is like we're here it's
the game feels like it's in a good place
now and I'm just I'm just [__]
excited man dude me too I'm so so hyped
I mean so Jean like we you and I we got
to kind of get a
like a preview look at the game right
like about a week early
and yeah they showed us a little bit of
the campaign and some of the destination
that's right and we got to see a little
bit of like
um a little bit of strand we got to see
a little bit of uh of just like you know
the vidoc a little bit early that
everyone else got to see now and there
was just so much to
process and there's so much to kind of
like unravel and one of the things that
I I'm honestly not ready for is one of
the devs mentioned like during the
viaduct they were like yeah we're gonna
be like you know finally all these like
loose threads are being wrapped up but
we're gonna like create some new
questions too and I was just like no no
no more no more blue threads no more
questions I'm I'm I don't know man they
got they got they got to set up for
after final shape right yeah but they
got to set up for after final shape too
that's that's true yeah that is very
true
that is true I guess it's just been like
you know we've been doing this for so
long that it felt it felt good to get
uh something close to closure in a way
and just knowing that like you know oh
there's gonna be another setup another
setup it's like I don't know how much
more my heart can take uh especially
because you know just the the whole
waiting game I mean just even waiting
for life all man and like took
years off of my life
yeah
yeah it's it's crazy because I remember
what back during uh it's back during
Beyond light when they announced like
hey we're working on witch Queen and
uh uh lightfall as well and it was like
I remember just being like well they're
announcing like two expansions like two
years in advance like that's crazy uh
and then like a year later they were
like Hoops we're doing one more
expansion as well um yeah it's like
we've heard about lightfall
for like several years now yeah so it's
kind of crazy to be like it's finally
happening yeah
oh my gosh my God yeah I'm so are you
gonna be you're gonna be on your Hunter
right
hell yeah I
chat I'll let you actually decide who I
should play first because all three of
my characters are
ready to go more or less
um dude I got such a my hunter is my
canonical Guardian it's my OG character
from my PlayStation one like yeah you
know launch day because I waited right I
waited until
um to switch over to PC until they added
the crosstalk save yes my character has
all of the Legacy like save data from
the PS4 version yeah
back in 2014 so I have a very like
emotional attachment to my character I I
envy you uh for being able to do that
honestly because I I ditched my I
ditched my character my Xbox characters
and I've seen this most people did yeah
yeah back when it came out I remember
that it was it was an interesting thing
because I uh
um
so I've said this to you before but like
the way that I was able to cope with the
fact that I just abandoned my my
guardian who I love so much uh was I
treated it like a like an Assassin's
Creed character I basically looked at my
Xbox character and I was like you know
what you get to be all tired and this
new character that I'm making on PC this
is my SEO now you know what I mean okay
okay
and and so I like that
so it's like it's not one's not better
than the other they're just different
you know like I just I I love them all
equally
um oh man chat seems to be equally
divided between getting me to play Titan
and Warlock and there's one
uh there's one Lone Wolf uh saying
Hunter with exclamation points all over
the place
Titan is so underrated please do tight
you know what okay maybe I will do titan
yeah you're getting a lot of Titan
requests yeah reading a lot of Titan
requests I just I mean so the thing that
that
stood out to me out of all of them to be
honest was the warlocks because of the
uh the thread links
um the Titans got the little you know
the Berserker claw so I might I might
try that out I'm curious how you feel
about Titan because a lot of people are
are a lot of Titan Mains are feeling
like Titan underwear into the stick yeah
with uh with strand
um
and uh so I'm kind of curious like how
Titan will actually feel
when you play yeah oh I am in
I am in oh [__] all right I'm not so uh
you go ahead and
okay and go well it is it is time
my friends uh so once again Chad just
keep uh keep an eye out like I think the
sound should be fine but if you know
gameplay kicks in and the gunfire is a
little bit too loud let me know I'll
just you know change it on a whim uh I'm
touring between Warlock and Titan right
now I think
so I think for the day one raid I'm
probably gonna go in
as a warlock which means I'm probably
gonna end up doing him last do the
campaign
so
uh Titan time it is I guess let's go
Titan Go man
all right let me so uh I don't know how
we want to handle this if uh if I'm
taking too long because I don't want to
keep the stream up
um for sure
I don't wanna keep the lovely people
waiting
uh but ideally if I get in soon right
away I think I'll just join your party
and I think we're just gonna go straight
for the legendary campaign I agree I
want one I agree yeah yeah we I think we
want to do legendary campaign
um I'm trying to hopefully uh the game
doesn't glitch out we miss a whole cut
scene remember how that happened last
time that's such Queen I do remember
that
and we were just like I remember like we
were playing we didn't even realize like
the cutscene missed were just like oh
that's kind of weird like it's kind of
we're just suddenly here now and then it
felt like there was like a bunch of
context that was like kind of missing
and then like it was like two hours
later we realized oh we like totally
missed a cutscene it just didn't play
for us so uh we have so one one guy uh
said Rob staff he was like we could all
wait together with a heart emoji now I I
I do I really really love the
camaraderie there but I'm uh I'm gonna
go straight in Rob I'm sorry yeah you
know everyone in uh in chat put an F for
Jean-Luc being stuck in the queue while
I get to go in and enjoy lightfall but
let's [__] go it makes it work
I'll be right behind you
all right cutscene time
the witness
the male effector of our first collapse
is that our doorstep
once thought to be a force known as The
Darkness
the witness revealed itself to be an
entity that instead wields the darkness
against us it spoke throughout Goofs and
offered us salvation if we submitted to
it
refused
though we do not know its true
intentions we can only assume it's six
to finish what it started during our
collapse
our resolve was tested when Sabbath
Union
I'm the goddess of trickery
disguised herself as one of our foremost
God healers
Osiris she gained access to our secrets
but in turn Osiris gained access to hers
everything had rebelled against the
witness and hid what might be our only
chance of defeating it away on the
planet Neptune
Emperor callus and his loyalist warships
have joined the witnesses Advance on
Earth but we've found an unexpected Ally
in kallus's daughter empress keitelon
and mythrax The Elixir leader of the
House of light
together we have United against our
common enemy
in an unprecedented mood The Traveler
left Earth to confront the witness at
all
this conflict was set in motion long
before we existed there but we will
bring it to an end one way or another
day all right all right holy [__]
that was good
I wouldn't know
[Laughter]
uh I'm sorry oh no no you're fine it's
funny I I think it's really funny that's
why I'm sorry because it's at your
expense a little bit yeah I mean I
didn't hear everyone in the chat I feel
like it's on there
12 units
the enemy away from The Traveler
at all costs
thank you
[Music]
oh [__]
[Applause]
oh my God
holy [__]
I have no context for anything that's
happening
the witness
oh whatever that thing is we gotta take
it down
[Music]
here
foreign
don't talk
don't die what
okay wow
well that was something
new arc solar and void fragments hell
yeah dude
be brave this is a classic Destiny 2
campaign enjoy it a loner with part team
of friends become Legends we are Legend
folks that's what we're going for
um
one thing that I am
tripping out about a little bit is
look at the volume of my headset a
little bit higher okay
John like are you still in the queue I'm
still in the cube I'm damn
I know whatever uh bungee Gods happen to
stumble on the stream and was like wait
wait
let's get him in uh I appreciate it yeah
yeah they got you in
yeah man uh we can give it a few more
minutes but
um actually you know that works and I'll
tell you why because we have folks in um
the chat telling me to get the season
pass uh exotic real quick to like whoa
new destination menu that looks sick
oh that looks so sick
uh Jean-Luc I wish you could see this
I feel like uh they said SpongeBob Meme
with the Squidward
Patrick and uh yeah playing the new
lightfall expansion
all right I'm gonna go into the menu
let's grab the new season pass uh exotic
real quick
dude um
Bill posted the uh picture of the the
ray jacket this year oh it looks great
this might be the first time I actually
buy the ray jacket dude I bought it it
looks real I'm like I actually I
actually kind of want that that actually
looks really dope it looks that actually
looks really cool
oh
my God
oh this is different
[Music]
oh this is very different
oh that that rules
you're a mess what I I appreciate you
being uh being vague I well I was I was
about to not be vague AF dude there's
something in this Tower that's really
cool I I I'll I'll I'll I'll I still
will
stay big don't worry uh but but damn I
need you to get in here oh my God I know
I know I need to get in here
a transaction to make Guardian
drop some some crap in my
My Vault to make room we're about to get
today
so that's gonna be
functions here
[Music]
are you [__] me oh my God
damn man
dude that day when I was up grinding
until like 5 a.m or whatever like I uh
clearly should have
made Vault space and I just did oh did
you not no I know I'm uh
now I'm paying the price you should have
cleared out your Vault man I was uh I
was up till like five six a.m chat uh
before servers went down because I was
trying to finish the seals because I'd
left until the last minute
so serif and MMX and all that it was
it was something I literally didn't
sleep and then I I pulled up to work
meetings the next morning just like in a
destiny days I could see like you know
the tetris effect when you see uh uh
like little Tetris blocks and like walls
and stuff after you play shiton attack
uh Tetris that was me except it was uh
uh stat building and
and build crafting numbers just like
hovering over the edge
oh man
all right I made a
lot of scrap here
[Music]
all right
and stuff
so now that's there let's grab this new
season of exotic for y'all it is
virgless curve stasis
oh
that's the bow they were showing in the
in the trailer this morning yeah yeah
yeah it's got a catalyst too natural
strings straight Fletching uh hail storm
stasis Arrow freeze Targets on contact
and create stasis crystals when
affecting the environment nice
and the intrinsic traits called hail
barrage final blows with this weapon
will grant those stasis arrows your next
hip fire shot will fire all of them in a
single volley that is cool
um kind of like a reverse um
uh uh tiku's sort of in the way it works
that's right yeah absolutely interesting
yeah it's very very cool
um
someone wants to see the new store stuff
if you want to look through uh oh
absolutely absolutely I would absolutely
love to uh
show you guys the new store stuff
in fact I actually let me go to icora
real quick because I need to
oh lightfold bonus items too I've got a
uh
I got a crap ton of stuff I got a new
[__] always
is that exciper
five upgrade modules
that's probably because we pre-ordered
which is nice
let me get the Exotic from Banshee or
exotic Catalyst Quest I should say
thanks
we'll be watching
let's go see what you got for me
uh yeah Chad I'm gonna go through the
Journey Tab and the accommodation system
and all that as well yeah man show them
all that [__] give me time and oh you
got time you got time there's there's so
much here to like unpack
uh
it's kind of wild
uh yeah man start building some loadouts
you know yay you got it you gotta you
gotta yeah that's right that's right
wish I'd had that years ago
[Music]
what do you seek
what is new fragments
we got defeating a Target while your
Shields are depleted grants you a
temporary void over Shield that's not
broken at all uh finish your final blows
create a burst of void damage that
causes nearby commands become volatile
okay uh defeating volatile targets
creates a void breach that's new I don't
know what a void breach is I've never
heard of that before
very well
so we'll grab that for now
let's see what soul there is
uh Ember of Mercy when you revive an
ally you and other nearby allies gain
restoration that's pretty clutch and
solar grenade final blows cure you oh
that's nice too
solar always it's like
um
out of the 3.0 it seems like carry the
left
oh definitely
you know what I mean especially for like
and game content type stuff that was uh
although I mean they've kind of toned
down a lot of that broke the [__] yes
they did yes they did
I'm actually really happy
all the classes especially as a hunter
like um I know Arc was kind of the most
underwhelming for a lot of people but as
a hunter I was like thank [__] god
it's a super it's dope
um
and honestly I really I really like
um a lot of the like effects like jolt
and
um
so it's some of the hunter uh Exotics
worked really really well with uh
it's actually probably what I'm gonna
run for most of the campaign until we
get strand
uh yeah I think so
uh we got some folks in chat asking me
uh
what does the director look like I will
show you in just a sec and someone said
I'm in the inventory menu they saw the
anti-barrier overload and Unstoppable
slots what do those do exactly so those
are Champion mods uh in certain PVE
activities like Nightfall strikes and
even some dungeons or raids you will
stumble onto certain types of enemies
that have a particular like port to them
uh Unstoppable Champions are just like
folks loyalty
they're like ogres or uh uh certain like
cabal enemies that literally will just
keep pursuing you like they won't get
stunned you can't stop them in any uh
Point unless if you hit them with a
certain type of weapon that has that mod
in the past now it seems like it's more
intrinsic and you don't actually need to
equip the mod anymore you just uh have
it applied
with certain perks so things like if any
of your weapons now have volatile rounds
for example they will work against
barriers uh any solar radiant effects
while working in spare years any Gear
with the Pierce traits while working
against barriers so they really try to
streamline that stuff and over here if
you hover over each in your menu now you
can see exactly what affects what which
I think is is a really
clever way to keep champions in because
you know for the longest time people
were like we don't want Champions
anymore because it restricts our Loadout
right but now there's just more options
to really kind of tweak your loadouts
around these Champion mods without
having to wait for like a seasonal mod
being like okay I guess it's Bose this
season or I guess it's Scouts this
season you know what I mean uh totally
bad stuff so I I yeah I do appreciate
that uh I agree kind of wild that uh you
know to that person's credit like I I
the games never explained Champions very
well to the point where
um you probably wouldn't like at first
glance realize you were even a thing
because they're just kind of like the
only reference to them would be in like
random mods you would find you know when
you're in your mod tree and
um I think I remember I want to say when
I because I took a break from the game
for like a year and a half yeah I think
when I came back like Champions had been
added and I remember being like what the
[__] what the [__] are these things like
just not understanding because again
doesn't tell you anything so you're just
like uh like what and like did not
understand that at all it wasn't until
uh like yeah like someone had to explain
it to me and I was like oh okay be well
yeah
it's like a weird thing to praise but
like I bunched you just at my quality of
life [__] you know absolutely absolutely
uh okay so let me show you guys the
journey tab um
uh so the journey tab is
it's new it's basically so before this
whole section was uh the triumphs
it was essentially the triumphs that you
would have and you could still see them
here you know there's like a little Sub
menu here now with the different tribes
and your titles you can change your
titles from here but this is meant to
essentially affect
um this supposed to change the way new
players are kind of integrated into the
game it helps it's supposed to help you
on board a little bit easier so you can
see what you're supposed to do and new
players will start over here at rank one
but they're a new life uh they'll be
asked to do certain things which I can't
really see what the requirements were it
just says progress one out of one so I
guess you know whatever they need to do
we've already done
uh oh no okay here there's descriptions
here so rank two Explorer you would go
into the cosmetrone and you would Age
Shah Khan uh rank three you get to go
across the solar system you can play
explore your skills as guardian except
there's seven
things here oh okay yeah so you would
explore nessus uh you complete some lost
sectors some patrols same thing with edz
this is basically all about
um
kind of getting to the other areas
although this is weird it says explore
Neptune and it says that I've already
completed that but I definitely have not
um
but maybe they just they just assume
that I you know know what to do for that
part I guess who knows uh rank four
Scout is gear modification that's good
it teaches you how to apply shaders to
your gear uh equip in economic or
tracking Mod on your ghost that's pretty
Niche that's nice gunsmith you get to
talk to Banshee tells you how to collect
legendary shards uh lets you purchase
weapons from Banshee you complete
gunsmith bounties during enhancement
chorus okay
light subclass
uh you purchase tells you to purchase
the fragments the aspects
I guess there's a light subclass quest
for my quora
and then by the time you get to rank
five then it dives into the weeds a
little bit with playlists uh what
Vanguard Ops are
Crucible for more Shacks Gambit Drifter
exotic quests collections gear
progression power trials okay hell
so what's seven so I'm at seven right
now which is Elite which looks like we
got lightfall complete delightful
campaign complete the weekly lipo
campaign mission increase your vendor
reputation with Nimbus okay season of
Defiance looks like we got six things
over here
it's all about increasing your rank
purchasing upgrades increasing your
reputation depending targets with the
Exotic bow okay
it looks like your typical seasonal
um
challenges got the artifact which is
nightfalls killing Champions and
stunning them
accommodations
doing Legend lost sectors and getting
the power up to the cap of 1800 it's all
the way at 11. oh my God it's all
question marks okay I would imagine
that's uh
great stuff you know they're just like
hiding it from us
oh [__] okay
or maybe it'll unlock once you reach
that rank is what it is okay that's
interesting
yeah jean look I am liking this uh
Journey tab
just like looking at it already it is it
seems like it's already a uh night and
day for new players because like
whenever someone asks me like I had my
buddy Dane who was like yeah what do I
do and I was like well if you want a new
story you can do the campaign if you
want to do like this you can do that and
just like given this long-winded answer
and at the end of it he was like yeah
that's great um so what do I do
and I was like I don't know like you get
to pick you make your own journey and
this one like this journey tab
specifically says
you know it's all optional right but
they're basically like hey
go to the edz or no sorry go to the
cosmodrome do that [__] then go to each
planet learn what lost sectors are uh
talk to your vendors and then come back
to the tower learn what the vendors here
do and then start your you know playlist
activities and all that and then it UPS
the ante into like you know all the the
greater stuff but I think the the best
um
I think the best part about this journey
tap is the fact that they essentially
kind of like feed you the option of
doing the more Niche stuff like here's
what the currencies do here's how you
get legendary shards here's glimp that's
interesting you know what I mean it's
like hey uh go to Banshee and do his uh
bounties and you'll get enhancement
chords like the or even go to the the
transmog um Tab and apply shaders right
like these are like the most innocuous
things that you wouldn't think to tell
someone unless if they specifically ask
like oh hey can I like change the color
of my armor or whatever
um but yeah so this is
pretty good I like I like that uh nice a
lot yeah that's it that's a good way to
do it I'm curious how um
players will feel because yeah I dude I
think that's like a thing I've learned
is
like what's cool about Destiny is it is
like you know it allows you to kind of
pick the stuff you want to play and play
and you can prioritize it but when
you're a new player you really do just
want to be told what to do for a little
bit yes I agree you kind of you kind of
need the game to just tell you to do
stuff and then once you're comfortable
and familiar with the game that's when
you can actually Bend for yourself
decide what you want to do but you kind
of need the game to like
hold your hand and just tell you like
bro just go play a round of crystal ball
yeah yeah exactly you're like oh oh okay
thanks that's me exactly we had some
folks uh asking for the store while you
know jelly still connecting I'm gonna go
holy [__] John look they have a touch
grass emo oh my god oh incredible they
have a touch grass emote are you
[__] me what's it look like I'm
gonna try yeah yeah if you have if you
hop on the street we'll probably see I'm
gonna hop on it might be a couple uh a
couple of seconds but wow that's good
destiny
the subtext is a uh I thought the
graphics would be better out here
oh that's really good wow yeah that's
really good
seasonal stuff
[Music]
archive damn dude this one moment please
is gonna like be burned into my [__]
monitor at this point
the the one moment yeah
if I had a plasma screen uh that was
still a thing dude that [__] would be
just like burned into my GG bro
uh okay so someone asked earlier if I
could show them the director I
absolutely can it looks completely
different
um
it's tight I like this I like this look
a lot
uh
um we still got the helm which is nice
got Eternity Dream City nice and smooth
jazz prophecy hey y'all want to see me
solo King's fall right now
healthy
uh okay cool in that case I'm gonna
customize my guy make it more strand
friendly
yeah ma'am
by the way I do think we should uh we'll
we'll hit a limit on uh waiting here
where um sure you know yeah I'll give it
like pop it on your own I'll give it a
couple minutes
yeah I mean I appreciate you always for
me but at the same time you know getting
a little get a little edgy it's just
like we gotta go yeah you know I don't
wanna don't wanna keep the gotta keep
the people entertained man what they're
here for that's right
uh
uh okay I kind of want to do just the
solstice stuff because strand is going
to work with uh
I already like checked expect out my
dude I I went for like a full like neon
purple kind of look uh to try and match
the the neo-muna vibe my guardian knew
deep down they're like I think I'm gonna
go to a 80s neon inspired City what a
what a Shader was that they used it's
like wave or some [__]
uh no actually I used
um let me see I I took a picture of it
um I'm like about a default to syncing
feeling so it's been like my favorite
yeah it's been a couple I I use a couple
shaders in tandem with each other
um
David has always been uh amethyst Dale
because that's the closest one to just
give me you're looking all black look
I used a combination of uh
I don't know how the hell to say that
but uh something Bramble just purple one
uh okay a skele uh burgoozian Knight and
donning celebration so I use like
to make it work
[Music]
s
okay
uh let me put my new Sparrow get my new
ship
and I am ready to roll
someone was asking what the new arc
fragments did as well because I had
glossed over them real quick one of them
was
uh
I'll Remember If I Stumble over here let
me see
yeah yeah spark of haste you have
greatly increased resilience recovery
and Mobility wall sprinting uh which
sounds like a no-brainer
and the next one was spark of instinct
while critically wounded taking damage
amidst a burst of damaging Arcane
between energy that jolts targets which
sounds like a [__] exotic if I'm
being honest I'm pretty sure that's
literally an exotic because if you take
a melee it's like feedback fences for
the title so it's a little different
because it's only when you're wounded
for the Starcraft that's still something
worth uh getting all right
should I look I love you I'm uh gonna
load in to the to the cute man
and then as soon as uh you know as soon
as you load in
um
[Music]
if you're not too far ahead if you hit
the point where like you're way too far
ahead then I'll just I'll just straight
up dip for sure
all right folks
uh CD Brill says can I make a Loadout
yes you can
um not right now though but I I will
after uh
after I dive into this for a little bit
um I should okay I do have my galley
which is good to
forbearance
I'm gonna use I'm gonna use the bow for
now but after uh
after a a minute I might just swap to
something that I think might be more
effective because the legendary campaign
is a bit of a bit of a [__]
um
here I won't make a new lit up but I
will
this one that I currently have I will uh
what should we call it I'll make that
and it looks like
I'll just it just saved it
it's over
oh swap Icon swap name swap colors you
swap the icon
swap the name
we'll do
we'll do alpha
Loadout Alpha swap the color
make it blue
yeah there we go hey there's my loadout
all right
I got a bit legendary disabled
galvanized more in order to put the stun
with Simplicity greater fire team size
skills combat yeah metal fix difficult
three-footed cars cap 1600 let's
[Music]
Guardian help Osiris reached the veil
before callus does and please stay close
to him
he doesn't have any life to spare okay
oh that's some uh vanilla Victini over
here
all right
Irma has been significantly updated
president characters
I'm checking our location we 've hitched
a ride to the outer Giants Neptune
orbits
Osiris was right the witness sent
callous after something hidden here
Guardian
and did not anticipate a fellow stowaway
calluses after an artifact on Neptune
the Veil
I'm working on a plan to stop him
till now find your way through that ship
okay
I have a feeling I'm just swapping to a
solution class for the uh restoration
the game is trying to tell me to check
my armor mods
three or four times
so get to know that the tool tips have
not stopped you
see that's the one thing
please stop
door lock your car is a chalice
house
that pyramid Festival
another weapons
on their back
thank you
wait I've seen this before
this looks
exactly like
uh pressage interesting
well that makes sense right cabal chips
kind of have that yeah
Andrews will say uh it's about you being
lazy but I think it looks cool no I
think it's being support yeah exactly uh
okay so I gotta look for a key card I'd
imagine maybe a drop from the dude that
I just killed but
uh maybe not
there
is
Emperor speaking
lions with the witness Bears such such
delicious
soul
stay vigilant with the witnesses backing
they could throw anything at us
the shadow Legion is one step ahead of
us any damage we can inflict on the
cabal fleet will buy us time we should
regroup as soon as possible but maybe we
can disable the ship's computer core
I've located the terminal here and sent
you their ship layouts
just received it locating now got it
we're not far from the core
foreign
Destiny 3 too but if you think about it
this is Destiny 3 essentially
Destiny 2 is becoming destiny
game
like an upgrade
um Final Fantasy 14 I think it's getting
one later this year yeah
um
or like or like I don't know man like
Ray tracing Ray tracing yeah
that'd be cool if they didn't I imagine
that would be the opportunity to be like
all right
I feel like I have a lot of expectations
dude me too honestly
that cabal had a key card it should get
us through that door
oh sorry what oh okay
okay yeah
[Music]
It's really because I raise the volume
in game actually
thank you
okay that should be a little bit better
um
but yeah dude I know exactly what you
mean also I think you're gonna like this
though this thing's pretty easy
let's try to try it out
it's that uh they're fairly odd man
the one thing that I always need to
adjust every time I stream is uh
the frame rate it's like
I don't know why OBS freaks out
I mean I mean you know this when we were
like troubleshooting this stuff before
we always have to like lock it to
succeed so I like go from playing
normally like 120 plus
to my monitor refresh rate being 60 and
I'm like just like oh I feel like I'm
like half a second slower than I would
normally be
right
little uh Shield stops
I can't help but feel like we should
have stayed behind to protect the
traveler and our people was it the right
choice to follow Osiris
the witness establishes a link with a
veil
over for the entire system
all of our losses would have been for
naught
have never faced the threat of this
magnitude
even if you stayed you wouldn't have
stood a chance against the witness
none of us would
this is our only hope to survive the
witness
that was the dumbest legionary I've ever
seen in real life do you just shoot in
the ceiling like
in the complete opposite direction of
where I was
but yes it seems like the veil is the
new uh McGuffin for lightfall it's the
new uh thing because I don't think oh no
oh no who is that oh my God the veil
actually has been mentioned
um but the weird thing is that like the
male has actually been
so there's like a little bit of hits
also uh the veil has been sort of uh
tied to uh a lot of that like
uh unused concepts of like that um that
like Darkness planet and and that like
unused what was that enemy type that
kind of people were speculating so it's
between the witness and yeah it's sort
of like they'll have more surprises in
store term that um
could potentially have been like
repurposed so not to imply like oh we're
gonna go to like that planet or anything
from that concept art because it's so
old and the game has changed so much and
it's like a Bunchy plan to do with it
but uh yeah weirdly enough the veil has
actually been a term that's been around
for a while that's that's a really great
description I'm I'm gonna apologize
because I like
got attacked by a Tormentor no [__] my
bad no I'm sorry like no no you're fine
I'm just saying that like my brain went
incredibly blank uh because I was just
like what is this thing dude it
tormentors look [__] sick also let's
[__] go did you
oh hell yeah
uh I'm at the first Darkness Zone I
could
just
get okay yeah I'm gonna watch this cat
scene and then um
this key card lets us access the
computer core let's head there now
all right
forbearance best Grand launcher
foreign
thank you
[Music]
okay did they set it where you
automatically
chat now I think so yeah all right I
gotta turn that [__] off yeah
I'm relaying my position to you make
your way to this [__] we need some way
to get to the surface I believe I have a
method to accomplish that did I detect a
bit of hesitation in your voice no my
impromptu status I have a high rate of
success
just get here quickly
receiving damage on the garden to really
increase the storage lunge distance okay
it's like a
eager Edge type thing
guard resistance
looks like I just gotta hang on to those
blues for now
oh okay
I forgot they completely reworked those
mods okay I'll take a look at the tower
later
uh Stratus Fusion yes I'm using random
finishers uh if you have a crap ton of
finishers you can pick your favorites
and you just favorite them and you
basically uh yeah you just at least on
PC just press shift I get to favorite
all of these different ones so it looks
uh
just varies it up it's really fun
I like to theme them based on um what
class I'm playing so the Titan has the
more like Punchy ones warlocks have the
more Elemental ones Hunters do the more
like flourishes and flips
down there
Alice's Flagship he's heading right for
the surface oh damn
my Shadows
dreams
of spirits when we win
the opening missions are always
just the best
oh my God
where's the first death
all right
okay
thank you
all right let me
just want to join up on me yeah yeah I'm
gonna join up on you uh I didn't get
that far ahead so we could just speed
through it because now we know what to
do and it's going to be a little bit
more
entertaining because solo is the easiest
way to do legendary campaign but it's
also a little underwhelming because the
enemies are so
like there's not as much if that makes
sense
uh but now with you here it's going to
be a little bit more hectic which I
think all right we're on Legend
we're just hopping right into it let's
do it oh wait I hit cancel real quick oh
oh [__] I did not uh because I think it
said I had an icon telling me that um
there was a checkpoint
but I don't know if that was a warning
for me being like hey you have a
checkpoint if you load in you're gonna
start from the beginning but if it loads
in that much point we'll just reset it
we'll hop out we'll hop out yeah
uh Dark Angel what is that bow that bow
is the new seasonal exotic it is
pretty cool I like it
I like it a lot
Guardian help Osiris reach the veil
before callus does please okay now this
is the beginning
he doesn't have any life to spare
oh hell yeah dude right look at that
little intro
thank you
foreign
it's interesting that they only showed
me on my screen and I see them only
showed you on your screen where uh the
other uh
yeah you know in the other like
campaigns if you spawn in you would see
the whole fire team spawn in right
locations
I like your uh
really good that's one of like those
Scion uh cloaks you know
I mean look at my [__] yeah
actually that gives me time because I
don't have any mods
[Music]
your way through that chair okay all
right let's get some resilience up here
yeah that's
the
oh they changed a lot
oh yeah they changed a lot oh [__] okay
there it's only into that one more
explained
all right stick man I got uh I got 390s
going on Mobility resistance and
discipline so that fast
oh yeah I prep I prep my character in
advance so I can do that oh yeah
uh and let's see okay mods let's see
what do I want dude
oh man
I don't want to like waste time on this
but uh [__] right there's the whole
armor charge thing now yeah the the
whole armatures thing I'm looking
through him right now too there's like a
lot of different fonts and grenade
kickstarts
okay what will give me our recharge
yeah that's the thing I don't understand
is what armor charge actually
does
um Midnight Cry what ornament is that on
my helmet that is a um it's the ornament
that's supposed to match with the uh Arc
exotic chests
uh which I should put on because then
you'll see this one they're supposed to
go together like style wise
School actually I like that a lot I'll
just keep that
crunchy armor charge collecting an orca
power causes of the game armor charge
oh this is cool you can just stack on
the the resistance mods
if you want that's really cool
I want a grenade actually it's full
expanded you gain Grenade energy
interesting I guess I'll try that
um
yeah let's do that
okay
ooh increases the chance of Special ammo
being dropped hell yeah
increase the chance of heavy ammo being
dropped
all right man give me that [__] I want
that seems like orbs of power what gives
you the Armor charge yeah yeah
um which is cool
Cartoon Network Power causes allies to
nearby allies well I'll put that on for
us uh powerful friends was that what it
was yeah yeah yeah I'll throw that on
that'll be good
rapid Arc
I found a blowskirts over power a rapid
kinetic final blows
um
I'll do rapid kinetic final blows for
now
based on the fact that I have
Quicksilver storm on
oh yeah maybe I'll
still
Quicksilver
just because of the
yeah that one's more based around here
commemorations
and I'll stick with wendigo should be
fine
the sniper resistance I guess that's
just a good safe one
I'm just kind of wing it here on this
[__] dude see what actually
although so I'll tell you right now this
is already like way cleaner and easier
to understand I 100
agree we're healthy meal begins to
regenerate upon picking an orb of power
that's pretty good
oh let's do that one actually yeah
uh Midnight Cry sorry yeah no not heart
of endless light are the most lights
different one but yeah curious of the
falling star that's the one that uh
is supposed to match with uh
the Helm of the falling comet
uh ornament
what's my uh heavy
void weapons get bonus versus ammo used
by that weapon yes give me that one
that'll give me bonus heavy
gain a powerful overshield when
performing a finisher
oh
we're gonna throw that on I want to test
that
King Harbor Church is a longer duration
okay
yeah man yeah yeah let's do it let's see
how it goes let's see how this works
[Applause]
the good doctor how long were we in the
queue before getting in I was only in
the queue for maybe like five ish
minutes uh yeah like yeah I got super
good uh 45 45 yeah yeah 45 to 50. I was
in there for a while
yeah I got in I got in pretty uh pretty
early you got that streamer luck that's
right
foreign
another weapon from the witness
okay so uh
okay
my faithful Shadow
this is your glorious Emperor speaking
prepare for descent bring glory for the
herald of the witness
the shadow Legion is one step ahead of
us any damage we can inflict on the
cabal fleet will buy us time we should
regroup as soon as possible but maybe we
can disable the ship's computer core
I've located the terminal here
just received it locating now
I was not far from the core
all right we need to wait in there
behind us yes
I like that like witness explosion that
they do where it like breaks out into
those 10 drills
that cabal had a key card it should get
us through that door
yeah so the key card's right there let's
pick it up and nice
oh it seems like armor charge was on a
timer too
you don't just get to keep it like uh
it's the temperature
I can't help but feel like we should
have stayed behind to protect the
traveler and our people was it the right
choice to follow ourselves if the
witness establishes a link with a bill
it'll be over for the entire
systems would have been for naught
they've never faced the threat of this
magnitude
even if you stayed you wouldn't have
stood a chance against the witness
none of us would
our only hope to survive the witness
oh my God oh my God oh my God
what was that
the fruits of an Unholy alliance between
the witness and callous so that did not
happen last time I'm pretty sure I love
it
oh that was scary dude what the hell
oh yeah
oh we got his ass
I got the key this key card lets us
access the computer core let's head
there now
communication navigation deployment
yes
just kind of past these uh
I'm already laying my positions to you
make your way to this [__]
we need some way to get to the surface
I believe I have a method to accomplish
that
did I detect a bit of hesitation in your
voice no
my impromptu stratagems have a high rate
of success
just get here quickly
I'm gonna need to start
on that level grind again oh yeah you
just got a bunch of Blues right and
they're a lot higher than uh oh my God
he's heading right for the surface oh
that's cool look at that big [__] dude
when we win
oh I love Carlos so much yeah isn't he
great
I had to write the first time the
Waypoint just threw me off
to get to Osiris quick
getting things done his own way
looks like he hasn't changed
and after
now he only has us to watch his back
okay
seriously destroy the engine
of this [__] the one we're on
crazy or not we need to stop this
invasion I'll do whatever it takes to
stop the witness so if you aren't going
to help me then leave me alone
foreign
was yeah
at least so far
but you know maybe we uh spoke too soon
yeah yeah we'll see because at first I
was like right I was like yeah yeah
because you got two uh
yeah yeah
the modifier says Legend hey there you
go
there goes Flawless there goes
uh
uh oh yeah okay we just got back the way
we came because we grabbed the key card
oh got it
campaign banners are free campaign
Banners are free to use they completely
fill your ammo use them to get a chance
there's no downside
appreciate it
all right let's go let's take out the
engine
foreign
I'm very excited to get the Catalyst for
it
thank you
oh
we're gonna get the other one okay
oh boy it got a little spicy I'm also
using a glaive so I'm just like oh
you're you're in there
it's really good it's probably the best
place in the game uh judge me to Calgary
uh yeah I think that's what it's called
I never got to uh craft it I'm like four
out of five ah
yeah seriously
foreign
all right let's get the heck out of here
everything's all dark give me that loot
oh that's lovely I love that give me one
sec I want to start uh
diffusing a little bit especially
because I'm actually full up on upgrade
modules oh I should do that
more we'd love that
I hope Tay's watching and see all the
get the the lizard brain of the the loot
to entice them back
this one see they're gonna do two things
it'll either entice them or it'll just
like confirm he's like yep no right
decision I'm never coming
all right
so the rest of this Mission we are
capped at 1600 no matter what the next
mission I know it's gonna go up so okay
the uh the infusing is still uh
worthwhile yeah yeah it's more yeah you
want to do it like
between each Mission I feel like right
yeah that makes sense
all right
sick I'm good hell yeah
just between us I'm not a big fan of
Osiris's Escape pod plan even for him
this is pretty touchy though
damn dude
are you are you the the Titans
it's a it's a risk reward because it's
like yeah I can take it but then I'm
also shooting grenades at my feed Point
Blank yeah okay yeah that's fair so it's
like it's like Titan Titan muscles but
also tight and green I guess I'm almost
at the Escape part where are you
are being sealed off have to find
another way
uh Logan I'm not sure what you mean
about the pre-order campaign
um if
you're talking about the like the
goodies the rewards you get those from
Rahul
I have your ornament for you uh
a bunch of like ascended
shards and Alloys and stuff all that
[__] still yeah you get your Sparrow
your [__] and all that yeah
stuff it's uh the ornament for the um
the Quicksilver is really really cool I
like it super diony
oh
[__] I got it
okay maybe uh when there's a good moment
to head back to the tower you want that
stuff we should get it before we head to
Neptune basically I think
I mean I'll I'll be like when there's a
good Lull in the story because I like I
like keeping them
foreign
the jolts the blinding and the uh
Amplified is yeah wonderful
I'm taking the armor charge stuff so far
yeah
uh yeah I'm still about 100 sure like
how the best utilize it but at the very
least like I kind of built it around
like micromades yeah and I'm getting
like tons of armor charges uh yeah yeah
like
[Music]
oh here we go
the double Banner that's right
it was like ornamental ships yeah
Donald Trump
surely is
enemies to like keep floating around you
know what I mean like all the ships and
stuff yeah that's what you guys look
after grenade user and I'm like
all right so we got the key card
uh where was the war oh over here
God that's a really cool
[Music]
foreign
I'm so dead oh [__] okay uh all right
okay
oh he's around you holy [__]
all right
all right okay so there that's where
that that's where the the it ramps up of
it is with these freaking tormentors
dude all right you know man I listen I
wasn't so sure about the tormentors
they're selling me on them oh yeah yeah
they are all right okay uh let me
here let me start let me start
stuff around real quick all right give
me one yeah I'm gonna run the bathroom
real quick bro okay that's fine yeah I
want to figure out what's a good way
when do those fine but it's not doing
enough it's more gloss DPS anyway
forbearance is I love it but I still
need to recraft it to get better perks
we will go
and
[Music]
wish
uh Gilmore yeah this is the introvision
it's a it's a really really it's a
really cool one uh we're probably about
three quarters of the way through
but no strikes yet we haven't uh
stumbled on any of the Vanguard Ops or
anything like that
all right dude we good
uh yeah I'm Gonna Roll oh
yeah I got a Wither word out
uh to be already rally
yo I'm gonna
uh yes damn okay that's fine
have you got the seasonal artifact yet
no I have not have you okay no no no I
was just curious because I was like like
oh [__] I should probably be getting
that you can perks on it yeah
what these guys
make a memories
it like scratches the same Edge that
Hammerhead used to scratch except it
looks way too weird yeah
explosive personality the special
grenade from uh from uh
it's good it's really good I like it a
lot I uh
I fully inspected out and I'm just like
super into it
I have a forbearance from uh
from a bow that's like kind of the same
thing as a dark
nice so but I haven't uh
yeah
all right so
we know what's coming
yeah let's be a little more prepared
foreign
all right
so oh yeah yeah
okay well at least not anymore
oh my God he's running no oh my God he
got me out of my secret my man
dude he's still chasing me
oh
get him get him oh my God
all right I like them they're cool what
the hell dude
[Music]
Abby you strand no we probably will soon
not let up he was
it was on your ass
I'd like direct hit him with my thunder
crash and I'm running Curious by the way
and he not only tanked it but he
suppressed him as soon as I hit him
here we go hurry up
are those things safe
all right bye
[Laughter]
oh dude we're in it no way yeah
oh my God please tell me I could fly
this thing I probably can't but that'd
be so simple I could
bring dog fighting into destiny
oh I'm in space for sure
that's gotta be it that's the mission
no I think it's gonna put us on the
planet oh you're right
Chris don't you do this to me okay
oh no you got the contacting as well
we'll see we'll see
fingers crossed
[Music]
okay I think we're good yeah we're good
there we go
so this is the the part that we saw at
that preview event Neptune yes there's a
whole city here an entire civilization
I've got a ping on Osiris's coordinates
let's find him
yourself are you with the Invaders we're
guardians from the last City flight
bearers we're fighting the same okay
we're here to find something called The
Veil
we'll turn down right now we'll be there
soon
[Laughter]
episode that oh good oh yeah dude
I'm into this
you remember uh
uh
Halo 3 odsd yes I get a little bit of
that Vibes
oh yeah
this is a pretty open area dude
oh look
you good oh yeah
again
oh nice
cozip says such a cool location you are
damn right my friend these places
pretty dope
that big callus
uh statue is kind of wild yeah right
where are these ugly things coming from
we always thought we were the last ones
left
wait until the Vanguard hears about this
no time for that no if we don't stop the
shadow Legion there won't be any City
left
Guardian I'm up here the thing that come
all know I'm here
hello what's going on out there
foreign
[Music]
in here
oh could this be it
oh
baby energy source this is incredible
you can wield it
press the grapple in the target's
Direction
oh my God
all right all right
oh my god dude strand is sick
your melee feels so good let me see it
bro
oh nice the little like kunai yeah I
know there's a way to like grab it back
to
oh we're about to get our super
let's do it I want to see yours first
yeah because you got the Rope okay right
oh what
oh my God look at that
holy [__]
yo
use it with the grapple all right Ben
pull yours all right all right
thank you
this guy just stuck in the air right now
oh that was it
it's like grapple the Buffalo
what yeah
I could use a hand over here
oh my God why would you use any other
words
I I think them being stuck in the air is
so hard
yeah wow
give it back give it back give it back
oh you look depressed dude
oh
more
welcome to neomuna
I'm getting big go-to energy from nimbus
I don't know about you no I feel that
Rohan makes me think of Reinhardt
oh yeah
all three is voiced by Dave Finley he's
uh Lee from The Walking Dead game I love
his voice
laughs
you work fast
we don't like to waste time well good
there isn't a moment to lose we regroup
at the Watchtower also they're huge you
don't understand we've got to get to the
Veil
I understand what's at stick like Bearer
or better than you
not all of us have lives to spare
damn shaming Osiris
I think it's like extra
um rough for the cloud barriers because
I want to say or
Cloud Strikers because I think they said
like once they like go the augmentation
they only have like 10 to 20 years to
live yeah that's right
oh here we go oh yeah
oh there's my boy
delicious power
I should be grateful that such power has
come to live in me
it's called for a toast does it not
my witness
progress the Veil
forum
it's still outside your grass my forces
are locating as we speak
the notorians won't cause much of a
threat with their tall and Green
Technology
the final shape Waits
there is
you have all you want
whatever
I am glorious
thanks to you
my witness
[Applause]
ES
yeah who could see that coming right
selling your soul to the witness might
not be all that it's chalked up to be
you know
yeah man classic callus he wants for
nothing yep
all right we're gonna eating up this
game
probably on the patrol Zone if I had to
go yeah give us a little uh chance to
here we go
[Music]
like that everyone's little to me
yo Nimbus just dead ass looked at me and
said oh it's my little Titan friends
although yeah no they are absolutely
huge this guy's a giant
so
you're the like
I'm not gonna claim my uh Mind's Eye as
anything special
but you hear Earth's Immortal Warlords
growing up and you think like round
Shields and pushy eyebrows
who comes dipping around smacking bad
guys with green stringy stuff I mean
that was
I've never seen anything like it
enough about you I'm Nimbus I'm the
rookie Cloud Strider here in neomuna
the cloud Striders have kept this city
safe for Generations
fans Guardians but seems like we got
lots of similar goals or at least
similar enemies
Rohan asked me to be your Guiding Light
for the time being
I'd do pretty much anything to keep the
veil and the people of Neo moon are safe
but when I took my oath I didn't think
I'd be babysitting
well then again mine's eye not great
now you know the wheel's in danger I
know where those big guys are headed
so let's go do some hero stuff
he's like giving like backhanded
compliments
he's like oh you know back in my day we
you know had like heard stories about
you Guardians and all that I didn't
think y'all were gonna be like this
though
it's like oh okay thanks bro she dropped
the seasonal artifact for us too did he
yeah
okay nice
okay cool rank rewards Hayden
can't grab any bounties yet
all right yeah this is in the Hall of
Heroes yeah there's the ascendant
scepter
hell yeah
oh yeah yeah
there we go okay yeah it's it's
thankfully it's a lot larger than I
thought it was because when they say
like three bubble zones or whatever
you see strider's gate Zephyr Concourse
and uh aimsa Park
and yeah in my head
yeah exactly because like you know in my
head I see those three immediately and
I'm like okay that's the range but then
you look down yeah like living Harbor
and then you even go further ESI
terminal or call it complex Avail
containment and it's like yeah and then
on the other side you got the uh the
Typhon and yeah sure so that's cool so
it's cool like it really does Branch out
you know which is which is awesome I
like that a lot uh okay cool so what do
we got awakened Queen's guard there's an
arena
uh post box vaults uh lightfall campaign
Hall of Heroes we could add a waypoint
there looks like there's two campaign
yeah although that one seems to be lost
hard reset yeah it requires polymorphic
Shell Code complete nimbuses weekly
Bounty interesting okay right which we
can't get the weekly Bounty until uh
later in the quest gotcha that makes
sense okay uh
hypernet current it's this campaign but
it has a strike icon so it looks like
there's a new strike and the Vex uh
Network it's cool
all right let me see if I can are we
able to buy bounties from him yet no
okay
okay uh so I figure we'll just keep on
the campaign and uh at least for now
forego the seasonal stuff I I'm with you
on that I think
um yeah I mean we we do have the uh
the artifact at least so we can start
popping things okay
overload SMG Unstoppable
Scout overload bow yeah Mr I'm gonna
start infusing I think anti-barrier
pulse
can you tell me what the recommended
light is for the next mission
oh yeah yeah
um
let's see
uh it doesn't say right now I think
we're just gonna go talk to us so gotcha
yeah that tracks
[Music]
thank you
WSS is this game fun to play alone I
don't have friends I was wondering if I
should get in uh I think that playing
solo is totally viable however uh the
more people that you get to play with
um the easier certain endgame activities
and uh opportunities arise and it's just
nice you know to have someone like hop
in and
streamline a lot of the stuff which is
great
uh no new strikes there is a new strike
um but I don't I don't expect there to
be too much on every corner at least
platforms
and what is the base power cap for
lightfall 1600 uh yeah or no sorry bass
power base would be 16. power cap yeah
power cap I think I think that's now
yeah I don't know that actually it's
like
gotta be in like the 1700s though
because it's like a pretty big jump but
all of your current gear will
uh be raised to 1600 when you start the
new campaign
uh automatically so if you're new and
you didn't do any level grinding during
the witch queen or any of the other
Seasons you don't have to worry about
that you'll just be raced up right away
so you can just hop right in which is
nice
I uh I like that
uh okay
I'm gonna go back to Quicksilver because
that's fun oh contact the servers let's
know uh oh that's not good
do you mind doing uh one very quick
detour to the enclave and then we'll
just hop straight into the next uh
campaign yeah okay where's where's The
Enclave uh in Mars
oh oh yeah yeah it's uh Throne World
totally totally
[Music]
um
oh this is my first time seeing the uh
the destination right yeah they changed
it it's cool nice the tower the tower is
actually the tower not uh not the
traveler yeah uh
sick Europa neomuna
um all right cool yeah we'll stop at The
Enclave uh and then actually I might
stop at the tower and just grab
yeah smart
Mr tank Destiny one was better all right
cool
good for you I guess that's how you feel
uh genuinely good for you uh I do not
feel that way yeah anyone but I like
Destiny one too but it's it's
not even close I it's it's very first
colored glasses in my opinion like I get
like get like the [__] like maybe like
when it felt like you know unknown and
and you were like discovering it for the
first time like that's the feeling you
can never get back but the actual like
Annex of that game like
I don't think they hold up
I hopped in uh to D1 and even just like
even just like the raid armor that I had
that I thought was so sick and I was
looking at it and I was like wait what
you know like I was so caught off guard
all of a sudden uh and just like hopping
into like the way that he like interacts
like I don't know we are so much more
souped up and
yeah Doper
so they got rid of the uh
material I wonder how that's uh I will
let you know because I'm about to
reshape this forbearance
let's be oh
so I can't change the intrinsic that's
fine really it's me it's good enough
anyway uh quick launch
ERS
yeah I'm sticking with quick lunch and
then High Velocity rounds
stands for Ohio
[Music]
I really am broke all right we can just
go to the next uh
one second
yeah I'm just gonna put the tower
crap so close
Bob Jones is saying the uh the power cap
is uh 18. 100 oh yeah yeah nice okay
there we go okay I'm good now we can go
to this hour thank you cool
yep that'll be real quick
I just wanna
run through grab my [__] oh now that I
have my uh artifact I can pop all these
bounties I was saving
oh yeah is it just the until you get the
artifact that's when you do it
before but I just wanted to play it safe
yeah
defying key automatically consumed when
opening season of Defiance Battlegrounds
chest unlock bonus rewards oh yeah they
changed the materials right so there's
no
like seasonal materials anymore now it's
just keys and the keys aren't guaranteed
either
the keys aren't guaranteed uh but what
it is is like the base rewards you get
are better or better it's a compensate
right and then the keys are like really
good [__] like they're trying to
whoa dude the tower's so different oh
this is your first time in here yeah bro
okay look okay yo they got a tree now
they got a tree you got cabals posted up
and the Fallen are like looking at him
like what is this look at a Petra's uh
the Queen's guard or whatever from
dreaming City it's our whole crew and
then look at this dude they got a cade
monument and you can hear a message
even departed Sparks like Cades it's
like a trace right we call the light
[Music]
crazy
all I I love this because I feel like
new players just had no idea what the
[__] Cade was
you know like what what crows uh point
of it all was and it's just like
I don't know there's just more mystery
here when they come in they're like who
is this person right and then you just
get to like yeah unravel that history a
little bit also uh there's a lot of
space over on this wall to add some more
people oh no
I I did not think about that at all
together look at the chicken
this kernel
remember Kate's chicken oh it's Kate's
chicken oh dude that's [__] awesome
[Music]
Monument to Fellowship oh hell Lord of
the Rings of them
[Laughter]
I love this redesigned
yeah that's cool also uh like the fleet
of um all the different ships yes uh
protecting the city where the traveler
was that's really right dude yeah
because traveler's gone man
well they're really leading up the like
the real Destiny was the friendships we
made along the way kind of energy
in the last season he's like you don't
need me now that you all have each other
this is so anime
but yeah no it's cool you can see yeah
you see like Petra's chips like the
Queen's uh guard there you have the The
Elixir like catches you've got the cabal
ships like we really are all just kind
of like uniting you know
[Music]
all right so just give me a sec I'm just
gonna pop all these brownies yeah I'm
just gonna see you burst with the light
from uh all right let's see what level
like how far I can get I I didn't go too
hard in the Bounty stuff but I
let's see
all right I got to eight we're good
oh eat better than me I only got to like
six and a half
[Music]
that looks dope oh man
all this money
um
uh where is okay yeah here we go
all right
let me just grab my [__] real quick
oh wow that is a cool looking uh
ornament right ornament yeah
all right also let me uh B isn't it
travel in a different position but not
gone correct correct uh yeah it's just
floating above uh it's floating up in
space right now
you can't see it anymore in the in the
sky box but it's up there
all right let me look at this uh well
it's like okay that's a cool little uh
Little Sparrow it's good to see you
alive Guardian I just had a I just had a
really bad feeling
um what when The Traveler
blasted the witness with that light
right
um
for some reason I envisioned it as like
an attack
but in that moment the witness was just
simply staring into the light and that's
when it got the like vision of the veil
and everything being on neomuna and all
that right like on Neptune was the
traveler just communicating instead of
attacking like was it
I don't know revealing its the location
or something like
that
I don't know why it just like that
thought just crashed into my head just
now because if so
yikes
all right authorized Mod Solar
the armor energy costume
discounted oh interesting
thank you
here we go grenade ones that'll be
perfect for me
[Music]
first time you underway okay so these
perks just automatically work right
isn't that the whole thing yes perks
just automatically work
hell yeah
[Music]
okay
um
let me just go and grab
Catalyst Quest
[Music]
the only relevant bounties really are
gunsmith at this point right
yeah because I don't need Drifter I
don't need Shacks
maybe Ada
I feel like a public destination
threader but beyond that oh hey Banshee
uh has uh Judgment of a telegram I saw
yeah Does it include red border for you
or no no it's just a regular one I think
I think the red borders
um come from a seasonal engram
and that's where like it potentially
dropped from but I'm not entirely sure
[Music]
foreign
quickly run around grab my stuff and
then I'm gonna go how can I help
very well
the black Armory awaits your
oh yeah it is still shaders now huh
oh yeah yeah oh she sells like old
shaders that I like don't have that's
crazy
also I need to get the new fragments for
my quora yeah yeah yeah definitely okay
spark of hay scrape
yeah spark of haste is what I have
equipped right now and it's really nice
critically wounded taking damage by some
burst of damaging Arc energy that shows
targets cool
yeah let me grab
both of those
and then I want to grab the solar ones
as well
color grenade
top
picking up a fire Sprite Resort Grants
restoration
fragments are a really cool way to like
keep adding new like changes to the to
the subclass stale you know yeah yeah
100 agree
all right cool let me let me tweak that
a little bit
all right sick you good
uh I think so uh does Drifter have
anything uh he might if he's blinking
for you he just gave me a like a little
powerful engram when I interact with him
damn that bull looks sick
uh did you get the new one yeah it's
really fun it's really fun I like it a
lot
let me just check them real quick and
then I am good to head back to nyamuna
sick
[Music]
okay cool I didn't have that new
monarchy Shader
yeah see that's the one that I was
missing too
it's because uh I wasn't playing back
when they did all the uh
[Music]
uh I'm glad they're putting that back in
the game yeah
[Music]
all right Drifter I'm here to say hi and
then play Gambit
uh all right man I'm good you good I'm
back sick yeah let's head back over to
Neo Luna go talk to a messiah
all right
laughs
all right where are we headed
uh I think right behind us also hold on
one second I'm just gonna turn around
the Hall of Heroes
yep
wow
[Music]
wow that's cool this is really cool
oh I am
here for this I love this vibe
this little table
all neon aluminum bottles and [__]
nice and classy
there's a little fire pit what this is
sick oh dude this is all the little uh
puka or whatever oh is this is this the
the puku pond yeah oh I've been yes I've
been wanting to see this spot
oh I really like this
what I'm gonna Cyrus
my vision was true
even after years of speculation no one
guessed the Ishtar Collective made it
here let alone build a city we couldn't
find as per callous
his grip on the city remains strong but
it appears these Cloud Striders are
keeping him at Bay
for the time being at least
his pursuit of this object the veil is
of dire importance
if he gets to it first
urgency is key Guardian
we cannot fail
okay
we're tall as [__] the earthlings know
how to make an entrance don't you I'm
Rohan Cloud Strider protector of the
city of neomona welcome to Neptune like
that
never thought I'd say that
I always figured if light Bears came
here I'd be fighting them off
lucky for both of us we're on the same
side in any case I hope we can find
common ground
or at least common enemies
complete the Under Siege mission
you can listen to some radio stuff too
oh neomona news with civil news
accounts across the city indicate the
conflict between the birth Warlords and
the invading cabal Empire has advanced
to our Fair City the Vex have taken
advantage of the chaos to encroach on
the Western Front Transforming Our
plazas into an active war zone all
citizens are promoted to active defense
duties effective immediately repeat all
students stay tuned to neomona civil
news for updates that's cool interesting
that's really cool the implication there
is that the Vex have been a problem for
them for a while yeah absolutely
I I really like those optional
interactions and stuff because like it
really does make this universe feel more
alive you know it's like while we were
in our own bubble on Earth fighting our
factions these
this whole like uh uh uh Cloud Strider
race has been
essentially just thriving and like
crafting their own
their own story you know like so yeah we
need to get to the veil before kallus
and his shadow Legion let's get in the
city I'll open a radio channel with
nimnus 16 20. okay what am I at least in
21 perfect
16 20. yeah okay I'm at 16 19. so that's
good that's it
okay
let's go let's do it
hello
this city is impressive
[Music]
Cloud
Artisans live virtual
I keep the city and their slumbering
bodies safe we shouldn't get distracted
securing the veil of ocalas is the most
important task
do not delay
I love that what
uh just need to try to like explain like
lore [__] and Osiris is like
we don't have time for this [__] we
don't have time yeah
like no no I want you to tell me more
except all your citizens are virtual
that sounds weird as [__] no yeah
that makes sense though because we saw
those like looks like all the commotion
made effects
[Music]
that's the least of our concerns right
now push forward guys
on top of that seems like the shadow
Legion put up a couple of barriers
between you and your goals
I managed to Ping a key card using the
city's Tech that might work with
I'll keep looking around for more but
you can start there dude that mural made
me think of like OverWatch
thank you
kind of like the legacy of those
yeah looks cool I mean if you uh kind of
compare the cloud strategy to the
guardians Guardians started actually
like really like thirsty
The Game Heroes eventually where I think
the cloud started it seems like from the
very beginning
yeah way more honorable you know
yeah I mean even the class starters
think of us before alarms because it's
the last time they've heard about us
that's right yeah
yeah this boat is sick
have you get fired yeah yeah it's so
cool
you like stack those threes and then
when you do the hit fire like the
animation goes
I love it
right
also since I appreciate my forbearance
it is nice
I'm charging down the last few as we
speak
actually it looks like they're on their
way to you like they were
never playing the last mission of a
vanilla D2 when you were like hopping
through the city yeah looks like they
made a whole campaign out of that
exactly I'm so happy
I remember telling like Natalie and
everyone else like anyone who would
listen just like yo that last mission I
wish they could just do more of that and
it's like here we are
and it's like that loud City but with
the aesthetic of the the archeology from
type which is like the biggest shark
also really dope that we're kind of like
interactive construction
stuff now because the last the only
thing I know about ishar Collective
Destiny one yes Destiny one and then um
yeah that location Destiny 2
um which one oh arcology right the
arcology yeah yeah it's cool because it
like even though
aesthetically still fits the stuff
that's been in the game at the very
beginning so like it it all still feels
very good
it's almost like the bungee art team
it's very good at their job
[Music]
guys over here
foreign
[Music]
thank you
nearly to the number of mistakes
corruption attempts I'm used to let's
find ourselves a workaround the longest
we don't waste anymore time got us as
Horses are occupying enough of your city
Oh no I got turreted out of my blood
oh
trying to break down as well
determine the best way to move there
okay
there you go the classic
seems like your little friend Drew
someone wanted attention
the shadow Legends pyramid Tech is more
complex than I thought keep them off of
me while I override this
I wonder if you'll get a strand weapon
as a result
I'd imagine at the end of The Campaign
would definitely give yourself right I
hope so yeah I just gotta be like uh
they did it with space we're over the
course of the Year they'll probably
introduce more like strand weapons
um right
I mean I kind of like the way they
handle that like from like a story
perspective it's like oh you learn about
stations and then like over the course
of the year like the weapon companies
like start to like boost the technology
in their guns
we gotta like learn about it right like
how it works yeah yeah like there's an
actual age
um
plus I imagine there's still probably
like a fantastic in figuring out like
how to make that all work yeah for sure
oh dude I got worried by that uh
foreign
ERS are pretty generous I've been like
chilling on Three Stacks
foreign
I got it
oh it's a complex system I'm fine I just
feel a little off
[Music]
our ghost is too proud
yeah
we'll be lucky if the witness doesn't
have the veil in its possession already
God calm down it's always this much fun
is not my concern right now with the
amount of power the veil has I think it
can hold its own a little longer
he is
inclusively get the more I feel
strange oh no
what is that
okay
ghost is like the closer we get more
something is wrong all right it's the
Impressions radio some of our powers are
gone what is this device it appears to
be some sort of pericosal disruptor oh
you don't like that I should research it
more to find a weakness but for now
carry on
oh
incredible wow
Jesus also did you notice when you
rallied your super didn't uh
it's it's it's that's what the thing is
yeah it could just be suppressed right
yeah yeah you can't use your super
that's crazy
oh my goodness of course here's the boss
hahaha
they knew what they're doing yeah
they're like the virtual encouraging
complaining about how Destiny's all just
the ability to stand now
it's spicy
a lot of Palin fields
[Music]
our powers are still being blocked by
this energy
hopefully and Cyrus can find a way to
destroy these things now let's take this
guy down the old fashioned way I wonder
if that's where strand comes
The Strand is
avoid it avoid it somehow you know maybe
heavy that'd be cool
add a bit of Mystique to The Stranger
it's not actually from the pyramids you
know
right
well it's like the pyramids are the
darkness
for sure yeah yeah absolutely
stasis was a specific gift from the
pyramids yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like the pyramids were aware they don't
know about training right right
really fast
apparently lightfall launch had a new uh
Peak record
oh
that's crazy because I remember like
that happens yeah
it's like one of them like you know how
endgame and infinity War like not
everyone has seen
all the time you came out but it seems
like the whole world was watching
okay it's like you must see yeah
thank you
that was good that was a good fight yeah
wow that was good
yeah give me that [__]
give me that loot
oh yeah that's nice put that number up
higher and higher
that's a lot of Shadow Legion
uh over here
a lot of ships oh I see okay
oh boy all right if that is at the end
of the Maybe
all cutscene
we're too late
they've got the Veil
Guardian
I don't but this doesn't feel right the
veil it's worse than before much worse
oh
my witness
progress progress
we have captured the Veil
well the area around the vale it is
so it will take some time to break
through and Link the relay
add that the enemy presence
yes
chain rest abide
Witness
that was familiar
only much stronger this time
I feel
like
together
Osiris and Nimbus need to hear about
this
yes Guardians speak more please yeah
I enjoy that a lot
me too
especially because like I don't know and
in the beginning it's nice that our
voice is like dead but it's cool that
like this time you could hear something
like concern a little bit you know like
concern reassurance but yeah dude I'm
I'm starting to think the traveler and
the witness are more connected than
I thought because if the ghost is able
to like tap in the ghost is a part of
the traveler right like there's gotta be
sure this has to be more interlinked
than
from the cloud
Fitness
[Music]
Shadow Legion do me a favor and check it
out uh it might be a good time to cut
the stream at this point I think so yeah
we've been at it for for a couple of
hours but that was fun we got to see
strand got to see some of the new
changes and uh
gotta look around at new menus and get
some cool uh cool cutscenes but yeah
guys thank you so much for uh tagging
along if you have any other questions
about you know Destiny and you want to
see more content we will have a bunch of
Articles and guides as well as an
official review coming on gamespot.com
at some point uh I myself have been
writing some iron banters like it's just
these weekly opinion pieces talking
about what's going on in Destiny since
it's an evolving game and things change
so much so feel free to check those out
uh but yeah thank you guys so much for
for joining and I hope uh I hope you
guys get to play lightfall as well
see you all around
bye everyone